a crowd of hundreds breached the
defenses of Dagan's main
airport once inside the men were free to
move the only apparent resistance locked
doors as they searched for Israeli
passengers reportedly answering a call
posted on the telegram messaging app to
avenge
Gaza there are no Israelis here says a
member of the airport
St now they were looking for the plane
itself recently landed from Tel Aviv
passengers on one aircraft scrambling
back on
board as the rioter converged on the
russian-owned Red Wings Jet some
clambering onto it this woman says her
flight from Dubai was left in lockdown
on the
TAC because of an angry mob outside that
cannot be handled by the National Guard
the Army the special force forces or the
governor of dagistan were still sitting
in the plane dagestan's Governor called
the crowd's actions in seeking out
unarmed passengers cowardly but said
they'd been incited by external forces
specifically
Ukraine it's not a secret there are
attempts to destabilize the situation in
dagistan our enemies enemies of our
country create unrest in dagistan by use
of such sucker punches as inciting
ethnic and religious
hatred
there has been anti-jewish violence
elsewhere in the north Caucasus in
recent days in one incident a Jewish
Center was attacked and burned Moscow
says the West is using events in the
Middle East to try to split Russian
Society Israel says it expects Russia to
protect all Israelis and Jews in its
territory and act decisively against the
riers Harry foret Al
jazer